khaleesi's husband mike mora has died
following a battle with stage four
stomach cancer he was 37 years old the
singer's management confirmed the sad
news in a statement to et
quote sadly it's true that mike mora has
passed away we would ask all to respect
kalis and her family's privacy as of
right now
following the news of his death several
friends of the couple shared tributes to
the late photographer on social media
including evan ross who shared a black
and white portrait of mike alongside a
caption that read quote we lost a
brother yesterday we will truly miss you
mike thinking of some of the great times
we all spent together ross concluded his
tribute by sending prayers to kalise and
her family
the two share a one-year-old daughter
whom they welcomed in september 2020 as
well as a six-year-old son shepherd
kalise is also a mom to 12-year-old son
knight whom she shares with her
ex-husband nas
fellow photog brian bowen smith also
posted about maura's death calling him
amazing at his craft and the sweetest
guy he ever met quote today we will be
thinking of you at every frame great
example of why you need to live every
day to the fullest and be grateful for
every day you're here love you mm
maura opened up about his battle with
cancer on instagram back in october
sharing a series of posts that
chronicled his life since his diagnosis
adding that a doctor had given him 18
months to live the milkshake singer's
husband revealed that his symptoms first
started in september 2020 with the worst
pain in his stomach that he noticed
shortly after moving to a farm outside
of la with his family quote loss of
appetite pain in my back also started to
creep in finally decided to do something
about it it was a bit late but just in
time
maura shared that after a week of back
and forth he finally started to get
answers not long after he and his wife
welcomed their daughter quote i thought
the whole time that i just had an ulcer
with no idea what was about to come my
way here i was in a hospital bed during
the middle of the pandemic all alone
after seeing three specialists maura was
diagnosed with stomach cancer he entered
treatment was optimistic about his
diagnosis and hoped his message would
reach others who might be going through
something similar
quote you always see people post about
how life is too short how you should
reach out to those you love no matter
where life has taken you it is the truth
don't take your time here your time with
friends family for granted
it can be over just like that
you